here we have a paper
also just published in biology letters
um this is actually from the end of of
oh
looks like it's slightly earlier
actually it's not just just published i
just ran into it
adaptation of sperm whales to open boat
whalers
rapid social learning on a large scale
question mark
awesome awesome right and so you know
obviously
so they're they're looking at um north
pacific north pacific whaling in the
19th century
and so they're looking at log books
whalers log books so it's indirect that
way and then they're then they're
modeling
and so it's the and the modeling is kind
of a black box i didn't pursue their um
all
of the the data and the models that they
have online
i just read through this article
um where they say we've got all the
explanations online um but they seem to
be doing a really a really compelling
job here let me just share a couple of a
couple of quotes
some historians have suggested that the
success
i'm going to start over
some historians have suggested that the
success rate of open boat whalers and
harpooning sighted whales the second
stage in these whaling operations
dropped substantially during the initial
years of industrial exploitation and
that this was due to socially learned
changes in well behavior
the development of pelagic whaling
operations in the north pacific by
american whalers during the middle 19th
century is well chronicled in digitized
wheelers logbooks so that's the source
of their data
we assessed whether this decline
was caused so um
so they they do see that there are
declines in efficacy which will reduce
the effect of the hot set there it's
it's confounded by that it's confronted
by that but they actually they actually
have four hypotheses they and again
they're using their model to assess and
you know i don't i don't love the the
way that they've been forced to assess
what they're doing but the fact that
they lay out four alternative hypotheses
up front is such a refreshing change
from how most
so-called scientific papers are written
uh they say we yes we assessed whether
this decline was caused by socially
learned changes in the defense of
behavior of the whales that's their
primary hypothesis h hypothesis x they
call it
evaluating support for several
alternative hypotheses using causal
models
the first whalers on the ground were
particularly proficient
that's hypothesis one
uh the whalers initially captured
especially vulnerable whales hypothesis
too or the whales learned to escape
whalers from their own individual
experience of encountering them
hypothesis three so that's different
from the their main hypothesis and
that's individually learned like
individuals learn to evade as opposed to
their social learning there's
transmission of social
stuff between groups and in fact it's
even a higher bar than it seems like
they they're asking could groups of
whales have have
have communicated information to other
groups of whales and
they find and without going into the
methods at all
the between unit social learning model
fits the data better than all other
causal models producing a rapid decline
in strike rate as units learn defensive
models uh measures from one another
all right so a number of reactions one
super cool yeah two
um
really skeptical
you've got a bunch of mechanisms and as
far as i can tell none of them are
mutually exclusive so to say one fits
the data better
again i did not spend enough time and i
i just i'm not a fan of the modeling
approach right it was all they had yep
um so i i
but nonetheless they could all be true
and in fact but they but you know to
to hear them talk about it they find um
it was hardest for them to distinguish
between the social learning model and
the individuals learning model that it
was easier to get rid of the other two
and i think they may it's possible i'm
overlooking it and i apologize to them
if i'm about to suggest that they do
something that they actually did
but there's actually
more
range in here because you could have i
mean in terms of hypotheses yeah yeah so
if you
fans of our book will be familiar with
the style of thought but there are two
ways that you could get a change in
uh
group behavior or lineage behavior that
would result in improvement in the odds
of the whales against the whalers
one is that there's variation between
the whales and how they behave which
there will be and that the
ways of being a whale that made them
vulnerable to the whalers
began to decline because the whalers had
success against them and the ways of
being a whale that
were
incidentally more effective at not being
spotted or not being successfully
pursued then would propagate just by
virtue so that is so that's different
from vulnerable so their use of the term
vulnerable is like old weak young
whatever and you're saying basically
that there will be a selective spread in
a population behaviorally
and some behaviors that weren't putting
them at risk before put them at risk of
whaling and those that part of the of
that behavioral spread will simply be
selected out by whaling right which
won't read as vulnerable because they
don't have the demographic measures
and this will you know i don't mean to
diminish it that really is selection
producing adaptation and the nature of
the adaptation is immunity but that's
not social learning right yeah on the
other hand it could be social learning
and there are multiple ways that it
could be social learning there's a
question about
you know again individuals who succeed
and those individuals who succeed then
being let's say even mimicked by other
whales right a successful well you know
mimicry sounds like social learning
well i'm not i'm not discounting that at
social learning but i'm arguing if these
were humans right you would have two
things uh competing you would have um
humans succeeding at various things that
would propagate and you would have
humans discussing the problem and coming
up with possible solutions right now in
wales we have a highly intelligent you
know these are sperm whales yep we have
a highly intelligent
animal
that does not have language they
communicate but they don't have a
language right so their ability to
propose things to each other is on the
one hand it would seem extremely limited
from the human perspective on the other
hand maybe not right because they can
show right so whale communication might
be a lot more show than tell
but nonetheless maybe although um you
know the long distance vocalization like
long distance vocalizations right but
very short distance what you can see in
water and if you're so close that you
can see it um you're presumably at risk
from the same whalers right exactly but
you know i mean we see we see much
smaller toothed whales like dolphins um
learning special techniques for
you know uh corralling fish and hitting
them with their tails and things like
this
um
from watching but there's no risk to
them in the watching whereas there would
be risks i'm just starting
here you've got a mechanism for the
transmission of information that you
know
i don't know if whales can propose
things to each other by showing
but that's a possibility
and so you could get oh you mean later
like right like that was close but watch
this
right
watch watch what i would do right here's
what i did right exactly so you know
that could be fanciful imagining of what
whales might be doing might be
projecting a human style thought process
on them on the other hand we're talking
about a highly intelligent mammal
yeah and or like oh i did something that
worked i'm gonna i'm gonna practice that
a bunch because that worked and then
others watch it like oh look what he's
doing i wonder if that's what worked
right so in some sense the point is we
argue that consciousness is about
getting ahead of this process so
selection doesn't have to solve the
problem because you can actually
mentally model a problem yeah pool your
insight with others who are mentally
modeling the same problem and come up
with a solution that you didn't have
before that actually works and then you
can try it in the real world and see
whether you had it yeah
whales have some of our tools not all of
our tools and they have them in
different proportions but the point is
it interfaces very closely here with the
question of well how did the whales get
better at this right
so anyway fascinating stuff
[Music]